[Music]
to get your passport you to partner here
to pick up a passport please
yeah mini Tuesday's take down the man
Freddie mom I did you gonna be in exile
Amanda well no I'm too busy doing your
job
oh I'm kidding I'm kidding look keep up
the good work because I'm going on
vacation one of dorks what's up
we're just talking about the trip
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one
what are you gonna do you're Nick Fury
put some clothes on let's go for a ride
this is mr. Beck we have a job to do
you're coming with me fury just hijacked
our summer vacation I didn't think I was
gonna have to save the world this summer
what do you want Peter I want to go back
on my trip the girl I really like and
tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not I
mean it's kind of obvious
let's go save the world you take care of
the suit
I'll take care of the music
[Music]
I'm gonna get so many followers
oh yeah never never doing that again I'm
never doing that again
[Music]
the costume was great she knows I told
her you didn't tell me I figured it out
it's cool I mean I've known first and
I'm no longer but it's not a competition
you